hallo leute hier sieht auch mal waren
und wir kommen aus der terrakotta helle
was würden wir uns was ist wenn wir uns
im garten sitzen also auf die terrasse
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
das letzte video mit meinem bruder so
gut angekommen ist dachte ich dass ich
ihm einfach mal eure kommentare vorlese
und er darauf reagieren kann
erwartest du gute kommentare wir können
zucker nicht mehr sehen ich sowieso
nicht ich bin ja blind zu gut diese
selbstironie brauchen wir weiter
nächsten riechst du schon was ja das
papier besser co moderator war er sagt
erst so denn ich bin blind sie gibt
ihnen die zimtsterne und sagt guck mal
ich liebe ihre dynamik zusammen gerne
mehr von euch beiden hat echt spaß
gemacht und ich finde man erkennt auf
jeden fall dass sie geschwister seit
rockel einmal gesichter so und jetzt
einmal so hier zum schnitzen forum
hochbringen hinter der kamera
ich bin immer größer als du auch vom
verstand her
ich gestehe ich musste dreckig machen
du verbringst du deinen koffer die sie
denn sonst zu vertrauen zurück
zur genau so gut wie heute nächsten
traum montage mein bruder ist der beste
pace tester weil er weil ich bin bis
heute stecke quito
das ist ein guter hashtag schreibt dem
man die kommentare nicht der marshmallow
des jahrhunderts schön dass einmal
wieder dabei war
[Musik]
ich hätte gerne ein
das ist ein auto das waffen wir mal dort
das ist ein pick up truck der fast
60.000 euro dankeschön familienautos
viel zu klein
mein vater braun pickup truck und
natürlich für sich und seine werkstatt
er sieht aus wie eine männliche schöner
so vanessa was aber viel ich finde wenn
du jetzt keine schminke er ist und er
keinen bart würde jedoch schon hart
ähnlich aussehen als kind hab ich dafür
gestellt dass ich unbedingt kurze haare
kriegen damit ich aussehe wie mein
bruder aus wie du
bruder ist viel lustiger und wenn ich
mir die kommentare so ansehe scheint er
ein richtiger frauenschwarm zu sein
nein überhaupt nicht die gewesen
die frauenherzen schmelzen dahin wie die
kieler forscher sagen und wie auf euren
körpern hier ist die nummer dann machen
wir eine tombola hh zu geil ich feiere
dein bruder mega bitte mehr videos mit
ihm zusammen aber wieder seinen eigenen
kanal machen würde ihn sofort abonnieren
ihm geht nicht so viel essen gehen und
mein gott man sieht dieses video also
meine mama würde sagen hallo hallo bin
wieder eure ilona okay ich liebe diese
kombi dein bruder ist echt sauer würzig
musste so oft lachen gerne mehr
adventskalender video test aber sagen
dass war unser frühstück manche würden
mich jetzt gleich verantwortungslos
nennen mein bruder süßigkeiten zum
frühstück zu geben und einfach ein
bisschen die aufregung dann hat sie ja
ordentliche darf man sagen ich bin durch
das ist willkommen zur neuen rubriken
erklärt perverse wird hier erfahrt ihr
mehr darüber
mein bruder ist so ein lieber das liegt
wohl in der familie sein vater noch
nicht kennengelernt
zum video machen mein bruder ist einfach
mega ordentlich gemacht wegen euch er
ist man kann es aber noch nicht gleich
essen hat die hat packung schon halt im
mund doch aber sag was du schon alles
kannst dem laufen gehen selber aufstehen
seine sprüche sind eigentlich die
geilsten dem video wolf dein bruder
einfach drauf ist und mal wieder kostet
soviel komplimenten nicht zu rechnen
hier bin ich einen interessanten
kommentar quito so wünschen dass er
wieder sehen kann gibt es denn so was
was ihm irgendwie helfen kann eine op
oder sowas wenn dann direkt spenden
aktion für key doch das ist ja mal
wieder interessanten im spiel da die
sehnerven funktionieren
das bild wird nicht verarbeitet vom hirn
oder wie schön euch beide zu sehen das
hat mir viel spaß gemacht doch mal öfter
was zusammen ihr seht euch schon ähnlich
am schönsten ist wenn ihr zusammen lacht
[Gelächter]
mein bruder hat genau so eine schöne
weise wie du total süß mag euch zusammen
das liegt daran dass unsere eltern bei
der geburt auf dahin fallen lassen haben
sind auch noch erhöht anscheinend sind
wir auch die gleiche kellertreppe mit
einem laufwagen runtergefallen als babys
ich heute so wichtig auch durch die
sagen wir mal ein jahr später bin ich
dann runter gekommen
und das hat wahrscheinlich was in der
frühen kindheit
was für ein trockener humor spitze
rücken
über trinken bier aufmachen und dem
sonnenuntergang anschauen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nach mittelmeer mit quito er ist so gold
wie lisa allison golden interessieren
sich für den 9 9 aus welchem land kommt
wie coleman ist bilingual aufgewachsen
wir sind sicher auch bilinguale du weißt
ja welche strahlen können wir noch
sprechen polnisch können wir sie gut
sprechen
wie wäre es denn wenn ihr beide einen
adventskalender für blinde menschen
testete überfragt
großen so gibt es überhaupt ich weiß
auch nicht ob es gerne und habe und
jetzt muss ich sagen
und wenn ihr schon da unten seit läuft
das video so eins muss ich sagen haben
ganz viele leute geschrieben haben
falsch gesungen schneeflöckchen
weißröckchen kommt nicht aus den bergen
sondern auch dein weg ist
ich finde deinen bruder so unendlich
niedlich und sympathisch wirklich toller
mensch und ich hasse normally menschen
sogar mag sogar ein mensch der menschen
hast du gehört hey ich sehe deinen
bruder gerade zum ersten mal darf ich
fragen was er genau hat lange geschichte
und dann herrscht offenbar lange
krankenhaus
lankl auch fehler von ärzten tatsächlich
nicht auch wenn es so scheint ich musste
jetzt einfach mal sagen dass ihr bruder
echt super süß finde ich glaube er ist
der herzliche und lustigste mensch den
es gibt und ich bin so froh dass ihr
euch so super verstehen dass während ein
echtes herz also danke für diese tolle
video zum abschluss einfach das sind
einfach danke schön wirklich für 1600
aber das vorlesen würde jahre dauern
zum abschluss
[Musik]
so jetzt könnt ihr wegschalten diese
nachricht ist nur für bushido sido
vorbei und kann kanzler roth die musik
damals lag die musik hätte ich mehr
abgebaut oder